This is the uh the session from Hashi Corp
where we're gonna talk about running and scaling agentic
AI applications in production.
And with that,
my name's Cole Morrison. I head up our brand story
function and am our principal evangelist at
Hashi Corp, and,
and my name is Kyle Ruddy. I lead up product marketing
for, for Hashi Corp.
So we've been doing this for quite a bit,
Kyle. I think I came up mainly through
the software side and then kind of got
tired of dealing with
your type and was like, I'm gonna learn the offside.
Wow, harsh
shots fired already, yeah, yeah,
but you came out mainly through the op side,
correct? Yes, yeah, I was, I was big
on the system engineering side starting from
help desks,
kind of pretty much migrating my way all the way up
through systems engineering and getting into, to
kind of like this whole like DevOps concepts,
so much. Stronger on the on the
operations side when it comes down to to the dev
and the ops, which is kind of funny because
like that's that's that whole bridge
between things is, well it's it's a story
and something that we're gonna have to deal with again with of
course don't worry, we'll say like 50
million times in this talk, but speaking
of which, that whole thing, you know.
There, I feel like there's a number of groups, Kyle, in
terms of when it comes to AI. There's the folks
that are like this is the answer,
like this is gonna solve everything, and then there's
the rest that usually are like what
engineers, like senior engineers,
your parents,
and like doomsdayers that are like, let's stay
away from AI. It's got all sorts of problems,
right? Which group do you fall into?
I don't know. I'm, I, I used to be
on the, the latter side, but I,
I think it's starting to, to slowly
sell me on, on certain types of workflows
and certain types of, of, uh, you
know, support for various languages and what they
can kind of do and, and add to existing
workflows. So yeah,
that's, that's how it goes eventually you gotta adopt. But
then there's a third group, and that third group of people
that have just been doing this. They've been doing it for
a long time and some
of them didn't necessarily even get to see
what. Came of their work. So, we've had this black and
white picture up here for longer than
we intended, but it's OK. We're gonna talk
about a little bit about, I don't know if any of y'all know who
Frank Rosenblatt is. OK, this guy
was born in the 20s,
and somewhere in his 30s, like
most of us, he actually came into his thing,
you know, he was in neuroscience and psychology,
and he had this really
cool idea, which was,
you know, technically the human body is just
like hardware,
so is the brain.
And if that's the case,
Maybe we can make a machine learn.
So he got the US Navy
involved and they funded the very
first
machine learning
idea here, and they put it on an IBM 704
mainframe which, having spoken to some of you,
I know you've got some of you for some reason have those
in your on-prem basements still, which
is fine,
and he started doing something that
we now do today. He got that machine
with 400 little
photo sensors to look at. Thing
and decide a simple yes or
no. This was really big
for Frank. OK. He called it his perceptron,
and he was so into it and it was like
60s, he called it the Mark 1 perceptron.
And this was the first case of a machine
doing this. Now, if you know, if you've done any of
this stuff in machine learning, you know that
this is the first kind of neuron,
right? Now
this took off, right?
He wrote a book about it, Principles of neurodynamics.
He started getting a lot of attention. He built
bigger and bigger perceptrons.
And, and, and real quick, Kyle, like, have you
seen a mainframe before, right?
I, I have, yeah, you have seen a mainframe before.
It's kind of funny like for the size that
they were at the time, the amount of computing power
wasn't necessarily there, right? And
it's taken us so many years to get there.
And he kept going and going and going until
eventually people started putting out papers
and what and they're like, well, this is nice,
but what can we practically do? With it right now.
And we hit sort of this AI winter
towards the 60s
and Frank, like most tech
people do when we're caught in a loop,
went deeper. He's like, you know what?
I'm gonna prove you all wrong. I'm gonna take rats
that I've trained
and I'm gonna take untrained rats, and I'm gonna
try to transfer the training over to the rat by like
poking them
in the brain. Yeah, it didn't
work. It was very controversial, probably even more now
than it was. And he went off in the 70s
and.
Died a pretty early death and never actually
saw his work come into play because what
he discovered was actually the whole idea of a
machine, yes or no, but not just that,
what's called
back propagation,
uh, back propagation error in the sense that after
a machine is said a yes or no,
it goes back and weights all the yes or no. So
if we look at something like Kyle and like Kyle,
like. Has a beard, right? He's,
does he have a beard? Yes or no? Yes or no. Does he have glasses?
Yes or no. You do that enough times, good. If
the result's wrong, then we need to go back and
change the weights of those. That was him,
right? So if you think about what we're doing in the,
in the entire space today,
that's just millions of perceptrons,
and unfortunately, Frank never got to
see that.
But thankfully to the height
machine,
well, now we've got a lot of people here because we put AI
in our title, right, Kyle? That's right.
All right, so with that, let's dive into
two truths. Normally this is 2 truths and a lie,
but we don't have that much time to get into the lie.
So, uh, and really like the
AI hype is, is loud. Like that
was kind of one of the things that I was talking about there earlier
where I, I was, I was kind of a denier at
first. Like you, you have all of these promises,
you have all of this,
this, you know. Capabilities of what could
be and it was loud we
heard it everywhere like we made various
comments at even our own events and conferences
where we're like, you know, it's, it's not a keynote if you
don't say AI
that was hilarious for a long time
until like we actually started doing stuff with
AI and then it turned into not really so
funny but
the technology is also. So real when it comes
down to it
because that's just kind of where the the curve of
adoption really is trending towards that,
you know, we've kind of moved on from the hype
scale of things and I mean
it's kind of sort of still there but
we're also now starting to get to the point where we
can realize
some of that value from the the
AI hype cycle.
I have no comment on that one,
yeah, so the question is where does it fit? So,
um, we had a very fun
conversation with our, our co-founder Hashkurb
Arman, and he had a neat idea, right? It's
like, well, when it comes to Gen AI,
it's obviously not.
A general intelligence. So if y'all don't know that
it being a general intelligence is more like
saying, well, what if we build a bigger skyscraper to get
to the moon? Like,
eventually we're gonna run out of oxygen and die, right?
But it's not quite the loom, right? The Luddites
are like, we don't like the loom, it's taking our jobs to get rid
of it. So where is it? Where does it sit,
Kyle? Because it disrupts a lot
of different industries, right? It's
much bigger than just some narrow disruptor.
How do you see it in context of stuff?
I mean it, it could be applied into to
many different facets and I, I think that's kind of
one of the, the, the areas of the hype cycle
is, is really like where can you, you
know, apply this and it gets into such a
broad kind of capability
that you know it's kind of permeating into every
single industry, you know. For a long time
it was kind of funny to talk about, you know, how
like various industries are changing and
everybody's turning into a software company and
now it's kind of the same thing on the AI side where,
you know, kind of everybody can now start using
AI in various ways, shapes and forms
and therefore
how do you then kind of control it.
But the question is, what does this mean for
the ops folks y'all here at Reinvent
because,
hey, we're working in the cloud, and
when we've had some folks come up into the booth
like, OK,
we got agents, we got code being generated,
it's coming at us faster than ever.
The AI is like there's so, it's
in every single thing. What does this mean for me
as the SRE? And the biggest thing we
want you to walk away from today with is
this.
It's just another workload like that's
really what it comes down to
and and that's really what the session is going to be
about is, you know, trying to apply a lot
of those same things that you apply
within your infrastructure today
is going to be just the same way
that you apply that to AI
because again it's just another
workload.
But what is different?
Well, the blast radius is different.
Blast radius is quite different. We're gonna go a little bit, we're
gonna go pretty deep, sorry, on the technical
side, because we think if we, if you
understand the first principles
around what's happening in the software
itself, then you as the infrastructure folks
are gonna be able to better deal with it, right,
and tell people no or tell people yes when
you'd like to.
So in terms of how we're gonna get into
this today, Kyle,
yes, we're gonna go over the, the two planes,
the model and the ops plane. We're gonna go into
and talk a little bit about the blast radius
that Cole was just referring to,
and then how do we get to an actual known good
steady state where we feel comfortable
now, you know, kind of harnessing and using
and consuming these newfound AI-based
workloads and apply that to our existing
environment. All
right, the model plane,
you know what? I think we should have probably put this slide
before it,
um.
So when it comes to
thinking about this new world of AI
for the infrastructure and the software folks,
because there's actually been a number of software folks that have come up
and have been like, oh,
we gotta deploy this stuff now. I'm like, how
are you deploying it? It's like from my laptop. It's like
that's, that's not good. Much like
the perceptron, we're gonna try to draw
a line between one thing or the other, and
this one thing or the other is, well, what's
actually thinking. OK, the
brain, not to say the op side doesn't have
brain, and then of course what
actually runs. And in fact,
throughout this whole talk, we're gonna always try to differentiate
where those things are, because until you understand that
line, it's very easy,
right, to overoptimize on certain
things, get the wrong ideas, or at
the very worst, get up and say the wrong thing
because you're not really sure where it's coming from.
What are your thoughts on that, Kyle?
No, I totally agree.
All right,
so when it comes to the model
plane, when for for the ops people,
I kinda wanted to go over some of the
higher level components, and I keep forgetting
that this is right here, so I keep looking over here and
pointing at it.
But let's start with the most basic thing. If you're using
some sort of model, you've got the prompt. That's
what you're typing in. So you've got the prompt,
and then of course you have the model itself that's actually
taking the thing. The model itself,
for those of you who have done no research to
it, is not actually a brain, despite that looking
like a brain. It's the most glorified autocomplete
you've ever
seen. It's one of my favorite things, like, as
it goes through, it's just a standard deviation. So
when you ask it what's 1 + 1 and
it says 2, it just generally
knows that it's, it's just a standard deviation of
it, right? So
after that there is the entire
reasoning side of it. Now this reasoning and
tools kind of come into when you hear what an
agent's doing, OK? So that's
the heuristic that we'll get into a little bit when it's
deciding like, OK, well, generally
if someone says I have access to HTTP
tool or to like this documentation
and they give me this goal.
What, how should I reason about using those?
You have memory. It's gotta keep context in terms
of like what's going on now for the
memory side of it there's that there's not
just the actual tokens that you're passing up which
for all intents and purposes are just numerical representations
of the text that you've got, right? There's
also the evaluators as it starts
moving. Towards its goal,
you gotta actually check and see, are you there? These
become even more important because in the
world where programmers are hard coding control
flow, that's a little bit more predictable.
There's the supervisor pattern,
right? So this is where you've got one
top level agent or
program or whatever that fans out to other
supporting specialists.
There's MCP. I gotta put that on there.
I mean y'all have seen the MCP servers,
half of them are just a glorified wrapper for an API,
but in general they just make it easier to discover tools.
You've got Rag, which is more or less
before any prompt you do, going and
preceding that prompt with other things. So
for example, if you really want to get the most, the
most detailed answer on what. To have that
for dinner tonight,
just load up all of Wikipedia beforehand
and you'll probably get something interesting.
And then of course there's retries because
this is an agent, because it's not a human, it
might retry quite a bit, but everything
I just said there,
it doesn't matter to y'all if you are
in the upside,
because
It's just another workload, OK? That, that's
all it is. You're gonna contain all of the chaos
that is that programmer into
a container, and he's much easier to
deal with.
I'm talking about myself in third person, Kyle. Yes,
indeed, yeah,
but in the end those are just services at that point,
you know, those are things that are running that's out there, things
that, uh, that you need to know what they are,
but not necessarily like you don't need to know
the intricate details of all of those things
or even, you know, to the depth that Cole was
going into right there.
On the operation side it comes down to what's
in the uh what's running those
actual things
and that's when we get into the ops plane
and that's.
I'll go one more there
because that's the things that we know.
Those are the things that we know, love, they've
existed for a very long time.
None of those things have changed, even,
you know, we still need networking, we still need connectivity,
we still need compute resources, we still need
somewhere to run these various things. We
still need memory, we still need databases, all
of those things that we know and love and
have been using for probably more than a decade,
depending on your age.
They're still there. They're still there. They're still
required. They're still needed.
I have a quick question for the audience, like, who here
is actually in the data science, the
software side?
You, are you, who's, who's actually the ones like coding
this stuff,
right? Don't be shy. We're not gonna call you out,
or we will, OK. So there's enough here
where like
these are now for some of y'all this is
this is actually new stuff you've been trying to avoid it
but you do need to actually like dive in
and learn it, but it is if it
this makes you feel better, much like the
perceptron has been around for a long time, so the
patterns are the same.
So then building on that, what happens with
our our newfound AI powers here,
we have slight changes in the way that
some of these things are required to operate,
you know, when we think about compute now, it's not just
CPUs, it's also GPUs.
When we think about various identities, it's going
from like me as a person as a human. And
logging into something we now have these agent
things that actually are nonhumans
that they need their own levels of permissions
and access and those types of things.
We're dealing with different types of databases,
you know, instead of you know maybe post grads we're
now working with vector databases,
but in the end.
End of the day it's all the same type of,
you know, high level compute and
offer operating offers.
So it's kind of just like a different flavor of
the same thing. Obviously the way you think about
them and some of the stuff that you're gonna have to change, there are gonna
be a few things there, but like Kyle
said, it's pretty much just more of the same.
All right, so here is one thing you will
have to deal with as the ops
folks when it comes to the if you are
just using an API, right, if you're just
using like OpenAI's hosted
model or if you're using Bedrock or something like
that, this all becomes even simpler
because then in whatever application that
your software developers are building when they're using
these, it's just another API call
probably. Either hitting just the post requests
or using like streaming capabilities which
is now in HTTP, right? So
that's, that's, that's even easier.
You have,
I have, well, we put cluster on here.
I don't remember why. I think it was because
we've been so Kubernetesified that I don't
even know what life is without a cluster
file. Yeah, I don't, but we really mean
run time like whatever
you've got your. CPU and memory on all those
different things when you have a cluster of
that runtime, you can choose to put the
model and hosted somewhere in that, right?
Now obviously you're gonna need to put those in a different
type of runtime,
a GPU based runtime,
um, but if you're doing something like Kubernete's, you can
keep them right there in the cluster, and the benefits are,
of course, that it's close, right? It's gonna be a
lot faster. Access can be a lot easier to manage
and the like.
You can of course put in an entirely separate
runtime, OK, host it on its own
EKS cluster or its own EC2
instance or however it is you want to go about that. That of course
is going to
create separation of concerns. It's gonna be a little bit
easier to reason about it, but of course there's
gonna be the fact that it's separate. And then there's
edge devices. Now this is actually really
cool to an extent,
which is let's just talk like
kinda like hosting an enterprise grade
LLM, pretty, pretty.
Pretty expensive, right? Absolutely, it, it
can be, yeah,
I mean there's, there's LLMs, large language
models, and there's SLMs or small language models,
and so that is one of those things that comes down
to, you know, how are you managing the resources
and where do they need to live so that you can
either access them easier,
access them cheaper, or do it in a more
secure fashion. And the secure
side is where that really comes down to if you've
got a manufacturing factory
that manufactures.
Shaving kits, I don't know, it's your beard that's doing this for me, OK?
And they're coming down
a whole line here and you've got a camera that needs to evaluate
them and is trying to use a
stochastic heuristic of something like a model.
You can't just shove all of GPT on that.
So maybe you want to pick something like Granite, right?
So IBM's got their small language model that's a whole
whopping like 3 gigs, and it can stay
right there. It can process a lot faster, but
of course call back up to cloud. So these are kind of
the 4 ways. Do you have any other thoughts on the model
serving options? Nope.
All right.
So I and I kind of already touched on, on kind
of the, the three main problems there when it comes
down to,
you know, at the end of the day regardless of what type
of workload you're dealing with AI
or not, it's really all about speed, cost,
and risk, you know, how fast can you access
resources or really how, how fast
can your end users, your customers,
uh, if you will.
You know, access those resources, how
much does it cost
to maintain those levels of resources because that's
definitely something that's, that's more and more
prevalent as, as AI
resources and AI workloads kind of evolve
and work through those processes. And then
last but not least, of course it comes down to
security and making sure that you know agents
aren't running amok and having access to
all kinds of insane things
driving those cloud costs up,
yeah. Speed,
cost and risk. OK,
all right, and that's kind of where we come into, to play
with the Hashiorp cloud platform.
This is one of those areas where we really like
to apply a, a general, you know, managed
control plane where you can provide,
you know, a consistent operating model
when it comes to how various teams need to,
to generate those workloads, how they maintain
those workloads,
uh, and how they, you know. Continue that throughout
the entire life cycle of their uh
their existence and usage
and you know I know we're at the the AWS
uh event but however this is something
that applies to to all sorts of things as well.
This isn't just AWS but you can do Kubernete's
clusters you can do all sorts of things,
uh, well beyond just that,
uh, so
throwing that out there.
And then when it comes down to it, you know, we've
kind of touched on this a little bit already, but
you know, really what it comes down to is, you know,
this is something that we've already been through,
if you will, like as people, you
know, everybody is in here at a cloud conference,
so we've all had cloud programs at some
point in time of our career,
you know, we've had to go through the process of adopting.
Certain cloud services we've had to go through
and standardize what that looks like to
to then build on those services
and then scaling those up and that's something
that Hasha Corp has been there along the
entire journey. We've been around for more than a decade,
you know, releasing various products all the way back
to vagrant and all the way up to what we
have today with the Hasha Corp cloud
platform. And it's really
interesting that even our, our, our co-founder
Arman, he, he kind of likens the
this whole like AI adoption
and AI program very similarly
to cloud programs.
However, the one big thing that's kind of changed
in, in that type of aspect here is, is
the, the timing.
Like it's greatly consolidated like folks
and organizations really need to go from, you
know, we, we have a little while to, you
know, kind of implement things on our own pace
and, and now it's like no.
We need this stuff up. We need it up this fiscal
year or this calendar year.
So how do we get to that point? And so that's where we
see a lot of this rapid adoption when it comes
to the AI program side of things,
which is, it's kind of comes back to what we said
again. It's just another workload and that
and Armand's idea and what Kyle just talked about,
if you abstract the idea of an agent program
into just it's a workload, well, it's
a lot easier to reason about the entire thing and
so the journey is kind of complete in
terms of how you're gonna go about managing it.
All right. So, let's, I'm gonna hop
over to a, uh,
our, our demo here,
and we're gonna walk through, if I can, if
this will recognize my finger.
And I click over to the thing.
We're gonna walk through some, some of the, the,
what we're gonna be looking about as, as we talk
about that. And so, um, as demos
go and as demos go with myself and Kyle,
this meant that we dug a hole
and got so deep that we're like, let's just
keep digging
instead of making it simpler.
So we did to make
sure that y'all had something and we could talk very
deeply about it, we have an
application here that is doing a couple of
things. It is, so say
hi to everyone.
At the reinvent talk.
OK, so what we have here is
we have an application that's reaching up
to a supervisor agent. Now
this supervisor agent, his whole
entire, right, so here he's he's talking
to everyone there,
there, there he is.
I don't know why he's a he. I decided to use a he.
This supervisor's entire
point is to speak to humans, to
interpret human language, but in the Background
it's got connection to a specialized
infrastructure agent, and that infrastructure
agent, while the supervisor's using a
large language model, so bedrock to
interpret all of this in the background, it's
reaching out to a small language model
that we're hosting just directly on
EKS y'all. It's just in
a Docker image. I just deployed it into
an EKS cluster just like a Other workload,
it's talking to this, this small, this
agent that's speaking to this small language
model, and it's generating and it's entire
ideas. I need to interpret this. I'm gonna be
pass something from the LLM. I need to
understand and think about the infrastructure
side of it. And also I've got access
to what's going on in context of
of of our terraform deployment in our
organization. Now speaking of which,
this is where we're going to use that platform
that Kyle showed that incredibly beautiful
slide on, which is HCP Terraform.
So Kyle, just give, give folks a little idea
of, of this product, how it works
with Terraform.
Yeah, so HCP Terraform is,
is essentially a hosted service that allows you to
plan and apply all of your terraform
operations in a, you know, a centralized
service,
and what we'll walk through is, is kind of how
some of those features and capabilities are kind
of brought to life as we're managing these
various workloads as we go through
our demos. Yeah, and so real quick, how many of y'all
here use Terraform?
That's what I'm talking about. All right, so you
know that the beauty of terraform is
that it is code, and as a result,
when you're talking to your, to your
co-pilot or GPT or whatever thing and
you're using it to help generate the code, it helps
represent the actual state of the infrastructure
itself. It gives you a way to persist, whatever it is that it
did generate, whether it's good or not.
Now if you just let that go rogue here, if I Over
to to this to
to my little AI infrastructure agent here
and I say, hey, do stuff it's gonna do it
now whether or not it's gonna be good or not,
that's kind of the question. Well,
the platform here HTP Terraform is going to
serve as our human in the loop. It's going to be
able to make it so that when we go into our actual
like, you know, orchestrated workloads
here
if I can find the one where I deployed.
The uh the actual spaces. Oh, that's
right, I deleted the application, you did, yeah,
I deleted it. We'll, we'll deploy it later,
but regardless, if it's generated by the actual
AI, we can do stuff like, you know,
look through the cost the cost estimation
and look through set up policies to make it
to where even if it does spit out a bunch of code, we're
only letting it through if it passes certain,
certain hoops and the like.
So let's talk about the the architecture
a little bit here.
You can see here we've got the cluster
that's actually running this little AI
application. So Kyle, we've got, it's just another
EKS cluster, but immediately there's some
differences here in terms of like the node groups.
So yeah, so we have two different node groups
that that are down there. One is gonna be your, your
CPU node group, and the other one is gonna be your GPU
node group.
But you know,
essentially again,
you're just managing that. The same way that you have
all node groups, yeah,
so if you've never done this before, the way to think
about this when you're gonna go to set one of these
things up again, if you're just using
like Bedrock or something like that,
you can just skip the GPU thing altogether,
which is the value of it, right? You just deploy
a normal app, it makes API calls, and
it's just another day in Kubernete's world.
Now if you wanna host your own model,
you're gonna actually need to get a GPU
instance. In our case we're using,
we're using IBM's Granite,
and the reason why we're able to do this, and this is the
smallest GPU instance that that
AWS has, we're still, we've got our own
model running is because Granite here
is only 3 gigs, right,
so it's really small. You get it up and
running and you've got more than enough. Now
you might say, well, what's the difference between the
small language model and the large language model? For
most intents and purposes, you're not gonna
notice it.
If you're
like depending upon the space, it's trained
on a much smaller data set, so if you start asking
it really weird stuff about Reddit, it's
probably not gonna know it. It's gonna confidently
tell you something though, right?
Um, yeah, do you have any thought on the small language
models there, uh, Kyle?
Uh, I, I think they're really unique in the way
that, uh, you know, you can kind of use them in, in
various facets,
um, and especially use them in low cost ways
like I, I mean, I've personally ran
a couple of these like the smaller,
uh, LLMs or SLMs
on, on like a raspberry pie, you know. You
can run that locally.
You can do all kinds of, you know, really neat things
with it. You can start playing around with kind of code
generation in a very,
you know, low risk type of environment
without incurring a lot of cost. Mm hmm.
In fact, I've got an SLM. I've got Granite
actually running on my MacBook
right now, so,
you know, my battery's not even budging, so that's pretty
good. OK,
so.
But I will say for the agent part you're like, well
do I need a, do I need a GP
for the agent? Actually, no,
the agent still sits on the CPU
nodes, OK, it's just the model that's
on the GPU
and now suddenly you're treating that
small language model just like you're treating Bedrock,
right? So that's, that's the way to reason. About these things,
um, pretty, pretty straightforward
there,
uh, I think, and what we're gonna do throughout
this is we're gonna use this application and this
playground as a test ground just to,
to drive our points home about the different
aspects and areas of things. So
let's hop back over to the slides.
All right, so that was a look at the, the two
planes that we had talked about,
you know, the model plane, ops plane.
So let's start talking about some of
the, uh, you know, the various,
you know, paths, if you will, as we, we
start going through kind of adoption and, and kind of
what the variances kind of look like there.
Now when it comes down to the two of us
between myself and Cole, I find myself as the
ops person that I'm probably more on the deterministic
side. I, I won't
necessarily call myself normal, but I will liken
myself to say a normal
program where you know you're gonna have your, your.
Your goals, you're gonna have some tools that
go along with that, but you're gonna have a
pretty well defined path
in terms of how you go from point A
to point B and trying to provide,
you know, whatever value that you're trying to,
to, uh, to provide as part of a service.
Yeah, and that's, that makes it a lot more
predictable for the offside, right, because there's
only so many control paths, so you know what's
gonna happen
on say Black Friday. You kind of have an
idea you can extrapolate because it can only get
so bad or good, however it is
that you wanna see it.
But what we wanted to do here is comfort you
all with the first principle of actually not a lot
changes in an agent program. If you think about the
business logic in a normal program,
it's just saying if A,
use this tool, if B use this tool, evaluate
if we've got it done. The only thing we're
changing in an agent program, so you're not scared
of it is instead of your programmer writing
a control flow for the hundreds of different.
Was that your customer can send you a complaint
you just give the tools to the
LLM. We say, hey, this is my goal,
right? I've got some tools to solve it.
This is what I know about the customer.
What do you think we should, what tool do you think we should use? And
it's just gonna go in a loop. It's gonna say, well,
Kyle's asking about, you know,
shaving kits
in in haiku format.
And it's like, OK, and it's still gonna be able to
figure that out better than
asking your programming team to write a control flow
for it, and it's going to keep going, but I, we
have the word stochastic up here, mainly because I didn't
want to use determinism again and say nondeterministic
because that would be your side,
because you don't necessarily know
how many times it's gonna happen. Like sometimes
it's gonna get it done pretty quickly,
sometimes it's gonna get caught in an infinite loop.
But when do you choose
agents then? Because if Kyle, like,
you love determinism, right?
In fact, do you believe in fate?
I, I greatly enjoy a fixed path
on, on how we go from point A to point
B. That's definitely how I found myself as,
as at least I consider myself successful
on the operation side of the house was being
able to follow that line.
Yeah, so the question is, well, why would you ever
use one then? Well,
this is where if you look at the, the market in terms
of a lot of the new applications coming up,
one of the root
ideas that they're trying to deal with is messy input.
All right, when you go to a. Form and you're
filling it out and you've got a defined number of
drop downs. The reality is, is because
I don't wanna deal with all the different, the, the
ways that you could ask me stuff. I only wanna write
so many if statements and wish statements.
But now with an agent you can send
me whatever gobbledygook you want to,
and we can figure out something. So personalization,
so messy inputs a big one, and then personalization
the way you want to be spoken to, OK? People
get up and they talk, I don't know, for 10 minutes
about.
I have what
the Dodgers.
Well, you can't say shaving kits anymore. Yeah,
I can't say shaving kits, so we'll go to,
to, to, to baseball. You have no idea what they're saying,
OK? You can get it like, hey, can
you just tell it to me in plain English or
whatever now that can actually happen.
And, but if your developer's gotta do that, that's,
that's gonna be, it's gonna be,
you know, not as well. But long tail
questions and edge cases, Kyle, how much do you love
filing tickets and dealing with tickets for that,
uh, as the receiver of tickets.
I do not love that,
right? And that's something we both vibe on, right?
We code and develop for the 80%,
and then the other 20% are a nonstop
stream of tickets. And then of course
there's tons of data,
tons and tons of data. If you think about the
way that these things are going nowadays, tons and tons
of data is a lot easier to deal with, right? It's just
all pattern matching.
But bigger blast radius
is still at the end of the day
all that changes here is this
If you understand those two, those two
things we just said, you can kind of fill in the blanks
of everything else that we're gonna do here, right? You can
kind of understand. So the analogy we wanted
to throw as a working through line through all
of this was think of your infrastructure
and the into it like a venue, OK?
You have the rate at which people Coming in
and moving about, you have the reach
in terms of what they can access
inside of it and out from it. And you have
the resourcing, which is how big should the venue be,
how much bigger should we make it, how many rooms should we open
it up, how much does it cost, and the like.
It's something that we experience every day
as we go, come into and leave
this event.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we do, don't we?
So let's step into actually
going through these three.
So in terms of rate, Kyle,
when you're looking at your infrastructure, how does that
look in a normal programs world?
Yeah, so in, in the normal programs world, that's
something that you have well defined. You know
exactly what that workflow is going to look
like. You're going To know that a person is going to have to
reach out to say a web page to
access something. That web page is then going to hit
something on the back end that's probably a database,
and then from that point there's probably going
to be some level of computation that
is required and so you know exactly
the step by step process that that workflow
is going to take.
And yet on the agent's side, all those things
and tools and capabilities might be available
to the agent,
but you don't know which one it's gonna try first.
You you generally know that if your agent
walks into a kitchen, it's gonna get a plate out
first, but sometimes it comes out and gets
the meat out and puts it right on the counter. And it
eventually gets the sandwich. And so as a
result, the rate at which it does it is
gonna be a little bit more unpredictable. It might
call the same tool 3 or 4 times
as it's trying to figure out, as opposed to just
1 time.
But of course the implications for that are
the problems.
Yeah, and that's that's
that that and part of the problems there
is, is that when you kind of don't know what that
path is going to be, you run into
those issues of what happens when
requests start queuing up
or you have too many like, you
know, using the venue example, you know what
happens when everybody tries to get into a
keynote at the very same time and
it starts flooding the system.
You know, and then then at that point you have to look into,
you know, OK, so what's the, what's the response
to that if there's too many people waiting, maybe
you need to bring in additional workers to
then start, you know, helping, you know, queue
the line in, in more appropriate terms.
However, if you move workers from one place to
another, what happens to the, uh, the workers
that were existing and what happens to the
lines at at work. They, you know, used
to exist,
turned it into a very noisy neighbor type scenario.
Yep, noisy neighbors. Good job.
And there's retries too,
right? We're as humans, at least polite enough
to stop asking after a few times. Well,
maybe not all of us, but
agents are gonna just keep going. They're just gonna be like, hey,
can we get in?
So, all right.
So this comes down to 3 big problems.
And in context of the, the through line of
our analogy here, we want you to think about pacing the
front door in your infrastructure.
We want you to pace the number of
workers that you've got going about, right? You don't
want to just
optimistically hire like, I don't know how many
bartenders for the venue if no one's gonna show up,
right? And then the retries, that's the
other thing, the main things that you need to deal with as
the ops people. The other stuff,
and the reason we're focusing in on these, because again,
those two planes, it is what
can you control? Well, these are the areas that you
can control without diving into the software and ever having
to talk to the programmers themselves. Let's
go through those.
First one, pacing the front door,
Kyle. So
I have got a program,
you know that it's gonna get hammered by all sorts of stuff
because we've labeled it with AI
and we've had our marketing folks pushing it out
so, so much like Jay Fry here
is in the audience who is one of the marketing folks.
And so we've got a ton of volume coming in,
but you can't touch the code because I won't let you. So
how are you gonna deal with it?
Well, and that's where you, you put levels
of guardrails around that, you know, at that point
you, you establish control in
how many things can be processed at, at
the same time.
Um, you start going through and,
you know, enforcing best practices. You make
sure that, you know,
everybody has a good understanding of what they're
supposed to do, what the process is going to
be, you know, this is a very similar
to like a TSA type scenario where if you know
that you're going through the TSA line, you're gonna have to
take off your shoes, you're gonna have to remove stuff from your
bag. It's a very similar process
just now applied to your workflows.
Are you saying that because you got stopped and specially
searched when we were coming in here? Uh, that did not
help us get here on time. That was. That was
special. Yeah,
that was from the, and then of course from the
infrastructures code side of things,
look, you're gonna see this as a recurring piece,
but in is, is the module on the policy
story. If you've got stuff like cues
and so me being the programmer
and we already don't want to talk a bunch, and
I'm like, yeah, but I don't know what that is, you say, here's
a module, go do it, right? Or if
I'm the optimistic one who's like, I wanna own the upside,
I'm gonna just start coding up terraform and I'm just gonna
push it out the door,
and you don't know about it. Well.
That's where policies come into play, which actually,
Kyle, maybe this is kind of a good time to like drop
what policies are so we don't
keep. Yeah, so, so before we get too far, this is
what I was referring to when I said guardrails.
So policy is code is a way that you can take,
you know, in essence, let's talk terraform for a
second. You can take your terraform, apply, you
can get the results from that apply, and then
push it through a set of policies that
you have established as code. This allows
you to say that, you know, in certain cases, you know,
hey, you can only,
you know, deploy certain types of EC2
instances. You can only define or
you know have access to
to certain uh compute nodes you can only do
or have access to certain policies,
you know, things along those lines that you can establish
those as guard rails as
your resources are being, you know,
prior to the actual deployment stage, but
you're verifying them before they get to that
deployment stage so that if you have
known situations where you don't want
people to apply them, you can stop them in their
tracks before it ever reaches your
environment.
So they're really powerful. We have a bunch of
uh various policy sets that are out there
that we'll get into in a demo.
You can apply them to various compliance standards
or you can build your own.
All right.
So I just realized we're, we're burning through time
here. So we'll,
we'll, uh,
so, so then the other thing is, of course, pacing
the workers. If you come in and you've got all sorts of different snap
and water stations,
how do you make sure that you don't overprovision
the number of workers? Well, there's, we're gonna get
a little, a little bit more into this later on, but it
still kind of comes down to the same idea, right? You
wanna look at the line, you wanna pace it, you wanna
force the line to make sure that, well,
the workers are only getting so much.
So let's go to the 3rd point.
And then of course there is the ones, the story
where you are gonna have to talk to your developer
at some point, and those are the retries.
This is how many times are you gonna let
an agent retry before you're like, OK,
done, like chill out, go do something else.
I don't know, Kyle, what's, what's a good, what's, how
have you dealt with that in the past in terms of like microservices?
I mean you can either establish a, you
know, like a, a, a counter. Counters
are always very simple, you know, hey, if you
do this thing more than 3 times, then we're gonna,
we're gonna hit you with a pause. You can do it
based on memory capacity or, or
allowances there. There's several different ways that you can
kind of use it. That's one of those things that comes
down to, to having a general understanding of
what your, your, you know, estate kind of looks
like when it comes down to infrastructure and
what those things are actually trying to accomplish.
There is one fun thing too if you,
if you can ask your developers when you ask them for this,
tell them to make the retry
timing a little bit random
because if you don't, then they're all gonna retry
at the same time. And while that's very
funny at best, like generally that's gonna
create more problems with the other services, so
I don't know, injecting uncertainty into
my deterministic workflow. I'm not
sure how I feel about that, but just a little, just
a little for the fun.
So this comes down to the 3 main solutions
to think about paste the front door,
right, paste the number of workers themselves, and
paste the retries in waves.
Thoughts and we're gonna take a look at some of the stuff in the demo
so we can get to the other things, yeah, yep,
OK, so jump into the demo,
the, the rate side of things.
Actually, LA is a that was LA. That's actually a good
thing. The rate, right in between there
is just to, to mainly show this is
there's a lot of different ways to think about rate.
There's not just the rate at which
the requests are being processed throughout your
network, right? And so if we were to go to say our logs here
and go into any one of these different logs like
around the API server or, you
know, so. The way that our different applications
are going through, you would, you're gonna see these
hammer through and do a lot more,
and that's the nature of those agents trying to do a
lot more work that you can't necessarily predict.
But part of that's also going to be the human side. If you
have someone coming in interacting with your interface
and they're they're trying to build out an infrastructure,
right, if they're trying to say like, OK,
I'd like to deploy an app
to
Uh, my EKS cluster.
Well, I might do this one little
thing at a time, right? But it,
I might do it in 10 steps, I might do it in 20
steps. That's a lot of more retries
as opposed to one web form where I
take you and make you fill it all out
very nicely.
Where you also fail a captcha, which is, you
know, always oddly embarrassing for everyone,
and then we get one request, we know exactly
what's going to happen.
So here we, by the way, so we see this thing
right now going and grabbing information from our
HTP terraform account.
So what other, what other stuff should we, oh, the,
um,
the policy side of things if we go and we take
a look at like, well, Kyle, I don't, I
don't know how to do a queue, right?
I don't know how to do something like that. We have stuff like
modules that you can use, right?
Yeah, and, and modules are, are very simple,
easy way to, to kind of easily consume
a common set of resources.
So 11 of the things that we've kind of called modules
over time is, you know, it's kind of the building block
of terraform configurations just
because it, it can take some of those much
longer, more verbose kind of configurations
and isolate them down and consolidate
them into a much more easier
to consume
type of block. So instead of, you know, having
to, to generate a.
Didn't see how many resources are in this one,
but you have 42 inputs for this thing,
just this, that one single module, and you
can consolidate that all into the module block
that's right there on the right hand side. So you're, you're
taking 42 different inputs and
breaking it down into literally 4 lines of
code in order to get this, uh, SQS
resource deployed.
So that's the human in the loop side of it
in the sense that you get to give both a.
And a stick they're like, hey,
um, go use our modules.
So this is like a networking, for example, where maybe
we paste the reach maybe we put
a networking firewall or a gateway in front of
it and said so only so many things can come in.
So that's the nice carrot way go use this approved
thing and then you can also of course set up policies
and this is where you get the stick sides's like, well,
you can deploy stuff, but we're gonna stop it
anyways,
so. Yeah, and this is where
you come into, you know, having a level of permissions
that are set within an environment,
uh, and the other thing that Cole was showing was, was also
a private registry, so you have access to both
modules that are in the public registry
or modules that are in a private registry
and that private registry allows you to customize
those those resources
for your particular organization or
particular use case.
Then getting into the policy side of the
house, there are also a bunch of sentinel policies
that are available out on the registry
as well. This is where we were talking about some
of those compliance standards that are out there.
We see the CIS, uh, version
there or, uh, yep, exactly
that's out there that's available. There's a whole bunch of,
uh, policies that are available as part of that. You
can easily invoke those within your.
Your HCP terraform environment
or of course because these are also
you know publicly available on GitHub, you
can also customize these to however you want
to and start applying them in
your HCP environment which is what Cole
was showing just prior to this as part
of the policy sets
so there you can see that we've kind of consolidated
those policies and applied them by
resource type so you have your RDS
policy. Set you have your S3 policy
set and you can do that and apply those
and you know
you can apply those broadly as well so you
can apply these at like your entire
organization level or individual workspace
level but like the nice
part is that if there's no S3 buckets in in
your resources there's nothing for it to check
so there's also not really any harm or overhead
when you apply it in in that type of way.
All right, so for time, let's hop
back over
into our stuff, and we're gonna,
I mean we were like, are we gonna be able to fill 60
minutes? It's like, well, if we're late and we
talk for a long time on one thing maybe.
So let's go ahead act two here.
This is the reach side of things. So this
is in context of what your services
reach out to, Kyle. So
yeah, so on the, uh, you know, the quote unquote
normal side, we kind of know exactly
what our service is going to reach out to. Those things
have been predefined. We have probably
created. Created some either IM roles
or or you know different you know depending
upon which environment you're using established
a set of permissions in order for that we
know that this thing is only going to talk to
these couple services which is, you know, kind of
uh displayed there with the arrows
agents,
I mean in theory you know what they're gonna reach out to.
Well, well, you hope you know what they're going to
reach out to, but that doesn't mean it's not
a determined path yet. Yeah, and you're like,
but it's like, well, well, hold on, it can, they only,
you know, they don't have access to so many tools. It's like, yeah,
but what you don't know is Cole gave it
access to an HTTP tool,
and now we can go anywhere that it wants.
So let's walk through the solutions to the reach. Well, let's
name the reach problems here, all right. And
of course there's many agents too, so you gotta think
about this, them all doing it, right? So,
all right, so we have 4 main reach problems, Kyle.
Yeah, so there's the overprivileged reach, you
know, and
I, I, I mean just natural
motion right there at this point, you know,
um, you know, somebody has maybe too
many permissions or too much access
to all of those, uh, resources that maybe
they shouldn't have access to.
Unfettered tools. This is what Cole was just
talking about with HTTP. You can do a lot
of things with HTTP these days,
uh, and it's getting simpler and simpler as we
were just walking through some of the, the, you
know, removal of WebSocket requirements
for, for even some of those HTTP,
uh, offerings
default open, you know, these are just known
open configurations where, you know, you
just by default have access to stuff.
Or then how do you get out?
So how do you know, think about the next
steps, the next iterations along that
process, that agent reaching out to something, and then
where does that go from there?
Nice. So let's go ahead and walk through
each of the solutions real quick here for this. First
up, for your agents, give them all their own identity.
All right. Do not give them your user credentials. Don't
give them your machine's credentials. Give them their
own separate credentials.
Give them their own separate credentials.
This makes auditing boring
in a good way, right, because you know exactly
what agent was doing what and when and where. If
it's bound to your user of the machine, then you've got
that all stacked up in one place and it's a lot
more difficult to deal with.
Why don't you do the next, yeah, there we go.
Yep and then you can bound it so you
make sure that uh that they don't have access to
tools that they shouldn't,
you know, making sure that you know if it's a specific
service it only has access to
those services that you have defined that it
actually should
instead of just giving it kind of, you know,
unfettered access to all the things you
actually go through and make sure that you vetted
the exact things that it should have access to
kind of still applying those levels of guard
rails to those uh those agents and
workloads.
There's the outbound story too. Even though you
might have an MCP server that has cleared
agents to only use certain tools,
we can go another certain, like, look, if
we're putting these agents in a kitchen, what if we just
cut, don't put a knife in the kitchen at all? What's this,
this is the blunt force way and this is something you all have
control over just.
Cut them off from the from a network level,
from a firewall perspective, from even reaching
the tool. So even if it does try, even
if you've put a ticket in to say, hey, don't
to the MCP server, whoever's
managing the access to that or to the software,
you know for a fact even if they try the network's
gotta cut it off,
cut off. Then
you get into the exit points, you know, this is where you
can consolidate those into a single gateway
so that instead of, you know, your agent reaching
out into, you know, various services and
those services going outbound from that point,
restrict them back in so that you know where
that entry and exit point actually
are and you have better control over those
things because you can establish various monitoring
tools and, and how you apply it to that
process. All right,
so this is in essence
how to deal with each of those problems. And again, the
value of this
is hopefully for the ops folks,
this doesn't sound
new, right? There's some new things to think
about in context of how the programs are, but this is
still probably stuff you're already used to. We
just call them different things. We use different
acronyms and the like, so.
I think let's uh we'll just batch the demo
here at the at the end so we can get through this
next one,
which is going to be resourcing. Now this
is the fun money one, right, Kyle?
Yeah, so this is how do you, you know,
going through and, and thinking through the, the kind of
the, the deterministic workflow,
you know, we kind of know what level of
compute or what amount of compute that we're going to
need for that, what level of storage that we need, what
level of everything else that kind of goes
along with that, but when it comes down to our,
our agent side,
agent side. Because of the two things we've talked
about, because we don't know how much rate's gonna happen,
we can have a good idea, right? Because we don't
know what it's gonna try to reach out to,
how many times it's gonna reach out to an internal service
and the like,
the amount and the way that we can predict the
size of the instance, how much of the
resources are being taken up, well, it's just
as non-deterministic as the agents themselves.
And that turns us into our resourcing problems
here where we have,
you know, various levels of, of conflictive
resourcing,
you know, where you can actually set up various levels of
controls along those, those
processes.
You can go through and have unmetered
resourcing,
uh, which you know that gets into various
other. Topic there and then of course drifted
resources which since everybody in here
has used Terraform before you I'm
sure have experiences a drifted
resource at some point in time,
similar concept uh just much
larger broader blast radius.
So let's solve each of these. First one is
for conflict of resourcing. This is actually
pretty simple to solve.
One of those, if it's a model and
you're hosting your own, you probably
don't have any other room on your GPU to throw it
on. So that, that one's pretty simple
for your agents though,
put them in their own node pool, right? You put
them in their own node pool, it's a lot easier to figure
things out and a lot easier to keep them from
overreaching into the resources that your deterministic
normal programs are reaching into.
You take this one or you,
you have at it. Talk about, OK, yeah,
so the, the next thing is the signal
based control. So this comes down to watching what's
going on with your resources.
So in, in context of this, normally
it's, it's tempting with a deterministic program
to go on patterns of what you're doing with CPU,
what's going on with the memory usage, maybe storage
usage for certain cases for the agents
themselves, you really wanna start looking at the
queue, right? I needed to decide, do I need
to bring another.
Bartender,
whatever, but,
a bar, another bartender into a bar with like
a line outside instead of saying like, well, how stressed
are you, Kyle, behind the bar?
Say, even though I'm concerned about
your mental health, right? I actually
care about how much big of a line there is. So let's
actually decide if I bring someone on based on the
line. So in this case, we're gonna look at the number of
requests coming into the agent as opposed to
how stressed the agent or how stressed the actual
resources itself.
And then for the last one here.
Yeah, at this point it gets into, you know, how do you kind
of throttle control for those various
resources and how do you start, you know, establishing
levels of, of either caps,
um, or making sure that, uh, you know, various
resources don't grow out of control and,
and kind of get into that, you know, unmaintainable,
unmanageable,
uh, type of format because that's also how we get
back to the point of having surprise bills.
Yeah, yeah, so just
that's we'll show. Some of that here as we get into the demo.
So those are the 3 solutions
here, but for time, why don't we go
ahead and head into,
uh, the last part. We,
we're gonna just show all the demo at the end here at this
point. So the point we want you to take
away from this is hopefully if all of this sounds
pretty familiar, it is because it is familiar.
It is the same thing, right? It is
just the same workflow, but
just a bigger blast radius here.
So again we have the analogy up here for
you and let's take,
let's do one more look at the demo here
just so we can kind of see everything
that's going on.
So we hop back over into
the into HCP terraform
here. Let's see here what is the, what is
the, the, the, the, the. Biggest
sort of win here. Well, if you have
say a developer that
has just generated a bunch of new code
and they've just gone in and they've done a
G AI thing like, look, I'm gonna make my own S3
bucket and they wanna come over here and
say provision it. So let's go into our one of
our projects here
and let's provision this new bucket here.
So we're gonna see the, the, the pretty
straightforward workflow of connecting this.
Come on, you can do it, thingy.
There we go, and that was
the.
The example
we're just gonna go ahead and create it
here.
Now this is one, this is the other side of the story
that we haven't really touched on as much, but this is,
I, before your developer was gonna be,
you know, they're gonna be looking through stuff. This time they just
went into GitHub co-pilot or Kira or whatever
and just got this done today. Now,
if you aren't watching for it, well, this
might not be very fun,
uh, very fun for you,
but let me go in here and just show you real
quick if I add
a, uh,
variable, I don't remember what variable
I needed for this. Let me see, what did I need?
Oh, I didn't need any. So this is just gonna try
to provision
a, a bucket in general.
Oh, that's named something. OK, we got something, we're good, we're good,
we're good. I trust,
I like, trust me, this is going somewhere, so we're gonna
put this in here.
So if we put this in here,
this is that Gen AI thing, and what we
already see that is going to happen,
Kyle, is something Kyle has gone and passive
aggressively done here, right, which is
Set up and established all kinds of guardrails so
that uh while you do have access to
plan out your terraform configuration that you
pulled in from,
from your repo, it is going to apply
it, uh, take that output from
the plan that we'll see here in just a second
and then start applying some of those guardrails that we've
established through Sentinel, which is our policy
is code framework.
So once we know those resources that are
going to be created or otherwise managed.
Then we can start applying the policies
uh and you know you can do anything from
time based you can pull in other
information such as what you'll see after the Sentinel
policies
uh are are performed and interrogated.
There's also cost estimation so you can have a
level of costing so you have a level of
awareness of you know what this configuration
is actually going to cost
in terms of uh uh cloud billing.
Agencies are all, as we can see, AWS based
resources
and then it'll continue going on from there
and we can make some determinations based on
that too so you know we can take
some of those as 3 policy sets
we can make sure that that coal is uh
provisioning all of those resources through the,
uh, using best practices both,
you know, industry standard wise
as well as internally uh
as well.
And then we'll also get a nice little readout of
that once the uh plan rolls
through and completes,
which is taking a little longer than it probably
should be because that's just the way the live demos
kind of operate the way that they work. So,
um, as we wait for this to finish,
I, I can go and spoil this for you, which is
that I made this bucket public because,
you know, I roll like that,
but that's gonna get blocked. But in the
background, Kyle's gone. And made a
module for me to actually use. He's like,
look man, I know that you need
like a bucket, so why don't I just give you
a pre-approved module, right?
And so this is where you get to this neat story to
where let's say we go to
your, your little application here and say like
I'd like to deploy
an S3 bucket.
And this is another area if you ever get around
to provisioning your own infrastructure
and you want an agent to decide to do it, that's
kind of a scary story unless you
think about everything we just did here,
right? If the agents coming up with this stuff,
just think of them like a rogue developer. Give
them two big things. Here are some
standard modules that you can use
to build from. Only use the modules. They're
only using the modules, that means they're only using
stuff that you've vetted and you know is good. And
then even if they're not using the modules, if
you set up the guardrails. Those policies,
it's gonna, you know, well apparently in our case, oh
look, here we go,
it's gonna stop. It's gonna say, hey, well this
is actually trying to make a public
access bucket, and suddenly you don't even necessarily have
to have the individual standardized building
blocks. You've got the guardrail set up so it can
just generate terraform. This becomes a human
in the loop. Kyle can come in here and be like,
Cole, and also,
you know, the cost apparently we
couldn't estimate the cost of an S3 bucket. It is
empty.
But there's also we have cloudability
with IBM. We have a.
Tasks set up through here through through them
that you can add pretty easily and Kyle, why don't you tell
them about that real quick because that is an important part of the
policy story.
Yeah, so another part of a capability that
you can add to your terraform workflow
here is the ability to reach out to third party
systems
and we're doing that through what's known as run
tasks. And what happens is a run task
takes that plan output and it can send it
off to,
say, you know, cloud already or Cole
already introduced IBM's cloudability offering,
which is a financial operations
type of. Tool set so you can see, you know, some level
of cost visibility through there but you
can also start using that with other
security based toolings you can use that with like
bridge crew and and PrismaCloud and
those types uh Cole was showing
us uh the run task uh registry
that's out there,
you know, there's drift detection, there's infrastructure
management, there's policy, there's quite a different
uh areas that are out there because we know
that you all are using other tools within
your environment and so how best can we integrate
with those existing tools that you have.
So this of course
helps the human in the loop side of the
story. This makes it so that the
speed,
right, you know,
having a car that goes 50 miles an hour is fun.
Having a car that goes 1000 miles an hour,
I mean that's fun. It's a lot more dangerous.
But if you've got this stuff in place,
what your Gen AI story is, is
again just another workload. Now
you've got the same things in place. So let's hop
back over and wrap things up.
And oh, we wrapped things up. So what we have
up here is a QR code for y'all. We have a
lot of resources. I know Kyle and I are gonna be doing
a more in depth technical version where we're gonna dissect
this stuff in depth since we're kind of
running over here.
And if you, we've got a little form there, if you sign up for
it, you can get more resources on us in terms
of infrastructure and cloud and context
of the AI world. And
what else, Kyle?
And yeah, please complete the the session survey
as well.
If you like this, if you don't, don't.
Details.